now lovers of sky atlantic's fortitude
will be rejoicing as the third and final
season of the thriller begins tonight so
who better to tell us more than a star
of not one but two of Sky's biggest
shows richard dormer thank you very much
indeed for joining us
you really loved playing as character in
Fortitude we miss it I'm gonna miss a
lot yeah he's just a brilliant character
very funny very scary very dark but very
yeah a lot of fun now you you've
described this character as your as your
sort of soul mate your friend why was
that why did you feel such an affinity
with him I just think it's that's the
kind of that the sense of humor that
that's in the show that Simon Donald
wrote there's a kind of I just just it
just kind of makes sense to me there's a
real kind of mischievous kind of quality
to even though he's incredibly really
quite horrible in many ways I also think
he's very funny kind of suited the bleak
scenery of Norway and the weather talk
about that how how was that when we moan
about the cold over here we like filming
everything it's like really cold I mean
I the lowest that I Clark was about -55
Mike you know what did that feel like
it's it's it actually it's not that cold
I mean if you're here and you've got
drizzle and a strong wind blowing in
it's December it feels a lot worse
because you're wet and you know but when
you're right there as long as you're
wearing the right clothes and you've got
a nice big furry hat you're absolutely
fine now of course that beautiful
Northern Irish accent you've got you
also had to lose that to play in
fortitude as well you do you have a
natural talent for accents because that
must be something you have to adjust a
lot in your roles I think so yeah I mean
I've always liked since I was a kid I
was always doing you know impressions
and my teachers and all that you know um
we need to talk Game of Thrones I mean
we can't we can't interview today
without talking back Game of Thrones one
of the most loved series on the planet
and obviously that's coming out the
final series next year at filming's
finish that finishing this summer
yeah what can you tell us
I can't tunnel anything come on just a
little they kill me we I've heard it's
been rumored that the ending may divide
fans is that true let me ask you
something lucky is easier to answer
there was quite an accurate spoiler
leaked to series seven online is
annoying when that happens yes it is
it's good for the show but I suppose
it's good for the show because it gets
people talking and you know and
sometimes I suppose they even leak stuff
on purpose I don't know but yeah it's
all good for the show it's it's it's
great but we find it kind of annoying
because we want the fans to see it on
screen and go oh my god I can't believe
it you know you don't want it to be
spoiled you want it to be a piece of
entertainment that is constantly keeping
you on your own you're on the edge of
your seat you know so now with Game of
Thrones of course you I mean you just
become known around the planet not bad
from for a boyfriend Lisbon in Northern
Ireland what how do you cope with Fame
do you like it do you hate it it's a bit
of both
yeah sometimes you know if you're
feeling tired the last thing you want
and you know you feel you don't you look
great and somebody comes up and goes can
I have a selfie you've got to be very
polite and go well you know actually I'm
done not today but you don't also you do
one out of people's feelings so that's
it but it is it's it's great I'm not
complaining I'm not complaining I'm very
very lucky very grateful to have you
know I've achieved this my stage in life
I think it's wonderful and of course
it's made you a national treasure at
home a local hero I imagine in Lisbon
yeah
well they're really kind of cool about
it Baelfire Samara Walker I said what
about you well yeah let's say cool over
there yeah there's the business I was to
say the words
Irish backstop to you you're reacting
earth's tilt I don't want to talk about
it it's just there don't just don't know
I just can't I can't handle it well at
least you're delivering us where the new
theories of fortitude like relief yes so
thank you so much indeed
et this morning thank you